Okay.
I certainly really surprised me learning
about the history of all this stuff.
At the birth of the drug war, it
was intensely resisted, right?
I think about here in La,
right? In Los Angeles,
there was a doctor called Henry
Smith Williams. When heroin was band,
there was a deliberate loophole
in the law that said, okay,
you can't sell her him,
but doctors can prescribe it to
people with addiction problems.
Just like what happened in
Switzerland, right? So here in La,
big heroin clinic prescribed Anslinger.
It drives him crazy.
He wants to shut it down.
So the mayor of Los Angeles stands in
front of this heroin prescription clinic
and says, you will not shut this
down. This does a good job for us.
But Anslinger shuts it down.
When the doctors say to the,
there's the biggest crackdown
on doctors in American history,
over 12,000 doctors are
arrested and rounded up. Um,
when they come to the one in
Portland, Oregon, the doctors say,
but what are we meant to do with all
these vulnerable, addictive people?
And one of the agents that go
and throw them in the lake,
they'll make good fish food,
right? That was the attitude. Um,
so this is resisted intensely
at the birth of the drug war.
So you had a society really recently
that had a much more mature,
exactly what you're asking about a much
more mature attitude to drug use than we
have now, right? It's not that
people thought all drug use is good.
We should celebrate every instance of
drug use. No one thinks that. Right?
There were problems and there were, there
is some joy associated with drug use.
That's actually the norm.
There is some pain and terrible
things associated with drug use,
which are mostly driven
by underlying harm.
But there are real harms that
come from some drugs as well. Um,
and most societies until very recently
had a mature appreciation of this. Right?
Really,
we are the outlier that most societies
have had licensed intoxicants.
Um, now of course in different
societies at different times it was,
I was the czar of Russia who
wanted to ban tobacco. Right.
And did terrible things to anyone
who was found with tobacco.
Different societies have had
different panics at different times,
but
we are the historical
outliers, right? I mean,
to give you a sense of just the United
States in prisons, 2 million people,
that has never been a society that
imprisons this many of its citizens,
this higher proportion of
its citizens anywhere ever.
It's overwhelmingly driven by the drug
war, right? I mean, the u s in prison,
so many people and the conditions in
those prisons are so terrible that the
United States is almost certainly the
first society ever were more men have been
raped. The women pass how
extreme this, this war is, right?
And what we do to people in it,
what this, what this, the, the,
the conditions this war creates it's,
um,
and he's a total historical outlier.
We are in a freak experiment, right?
And the one thing you can say
in defense of the drug war,
and I would give one bit of credit for
this, is we gave it a fair shot, right?
The United States has done
it for a hundred years. Uh,
this country has spent $1 trillion on it.
Uh,
we've imprisoned millions
of our own citizens. We've,
because we killed hundreds of thousands
of people that are conservative estimate.
We've destroyed whole countries.
Like Colombia
isn't the problem now that there's a
gigantic business behind it all from
private prisons to prison guard unions
to the pharmaceutical industry that would
benefit from keeping most
of these drugs illegal.
So their profits continue to
rise to law enforcement. I mean,
down the line it's,
you'd be disrupting like an evil industry,
but an industry, I think that's a real
factor, but I don't want to overstate it.
Lots of policies have best in the factor.
What's the main factor?
The main factor is most people asked,
do you think the drug war has
failed? So yes. And most people ask,
do you want to legalize any drug other
than cannabis? Say No. Very strong.
So education,
I think it's about,
I won't use the word education can give
you an example of a [inaudible] person
who I think showed away to do this.
Um,
so in the year 2000 in Vancouver,
there was a homeless street
addict called bottles, boom. And,
and he lived in a notorious
part of Vancouver called
the downtown east side. It,
um, people in Vancouver had
been to one knew it. No,
it's a place particular
at that time that had, um,
really high like nightmarish
open drug scene, Rogers again,
people need like in Switzerland,
people injecting in the streets,
that kind of thing.
And Bob w was living homeless and he was
watching his friends die all around him
at that time. Um, there was a
really big police crackdown. Um,
and so people would go and like hide and
dumpsters or in alleyways to shoot up.
But obviously if you're hiding and you
overdose, no one sees it, you just die.
Right. And one day bud, um,
Hitler's at one of his friends,
Judith had had died and he's like,
I can't just sit here and wait for my
friends to die and then for me to die.
But as bud would have put it, then he
also thought, I'm a homeless junkie.
What the fuck am I going to do?
Right. But had a really simple idea.
He gathered together a group of the other
homeless street addicts and he said,
um, when we're not using, which is most
of the time, even people on the streets,
what we should do is just drop a timetable
and go and look in the places where
we know people, where we she up. Right.
And if we see someone overdosing will
bring an ambulance. Now officials,
nothing like that.
Just us and loads of people had descended
on the downtown east side to come up
with problems to solve everything.
And people were very skeptical but
they liked bud. Ah, okay, we'll do it.
So they start going and searching and um,
over the next three months,
the downtown that the death toll on
the downtown east side like had a
significant fall.
And obviously that meant people
who would have died were living,
which is a great thing. But it
also meant the addicts thought, oh,
maybe we're not the pieces of shit.
Everyone says we are right.
Maybe we can do something. Then
we're like, what else can we do?
Bud went to the library. He
learned in Frankfurt. In Germany,
they had open safe injection rooms,
but like what happened in
California until they shut it down,
Anslinger shut it down where people could
go and use their drugs and be watched
by doctors and nurses and that this had
massively reduced deaths in Frankfurt.
Nothing like this had happened in the
United States since Anslinger shut it all
down, but bird's like, okay,
we'll persuade our map.
They set up a group called
Van, do the Vancouver Area
Network of drug users. Okay.
The Mare was a conservative right wing
guy called Phillip Iom who would be an
American comparison.
It's not Trump like Mitt Romney,
rich guy from privileged family didn't
get, didn't know anything about addicts.
He'd,
he'd run for office saying all the local
drug addicts should be located to be
taken and detained to the local military
base in Chilliwack and never let out if
she sends to where he's coming from.
Right.
People are not optimistic about
persuading him. Van Do bud,
his friends,
they decide everywhere Philipo and goes,
they're going to follow him with a
coffin and the coffin had written on it.
He will die next Philipo in before
you open a safe injection site.
Every time Phillip own spoken public,
one of the homeless people with addiction
problems with stand up and say he will
die next power him before you
open a safe injection site. Um,
one day Dean Wilson, one of the main
people in Vandy stood up and said,
do you remember Julia who asked
you recently? He would die next.
It turned out to be hurt because
you haven't done it right.
This goes on for a long time.
They do loads of public actions.
They filled Oppenheimer Park,
which big park in Vancouver with a cross
more than a thousand crosses each one
representing someone who had died of an
overdose and they wrote the names of the
people on the crosses and one day
after it's been going on for years,
it totally tastes credit. Philipo Ian
just said, who the fuck are these people?
What is this? And he went to meet
loads of the addicts. He sat with them.
It blew his mind.
He thought people with addiction problems,
people who partied too hard indulge
themselves. He was completely shocked.
He came here, uh, to the Untied
States to meet, uh, Milton Friedman,
the Nobel prize winning economist who
grown up under alcohol prohibition and
Milton Friedman Explains Drug
Prohibition to Phillip over it,
but it probably comes back to Vancouver
and he holds a press conference and had
the chief of police, the coroner,
and a representative of the addicts.
And he says something like,
I'm not going to speak again without
having the addicts here with me about
addiction because they
understand it better than me.
We're going to open the first safe
injection site in North America.
We're going to have the most compassionate
drug policies in North America.
Things are gonna change around here,
right? The open, safe injection site,
Philipo ins, right wing party is so
horrified. They de-select him as is,
as the candidate and his
whole political career ends.
But a more liberal guy wins
the election in the room,
stays open in the 10 years that followed,
overdose deaths on the downtown east
side fell by 80% eight 0% right?
Average life expectancy in that
neighborhood rose by 10 years.
You just don't get figures
like that very often.
And I remember the reason I say in
relation to change, it's, you know,
a big part of what I argue in
chasing the scream anymore that,
but lost connections is, you know,
we, you don't write people off, right?
But I realized I would
have written off Philipo in
right wing guy runs for saying we should
lock them all up in the military base.
Right?
You don't write off anyone.
You don't know who can be persuaded
by message of love and compassion.
And the most unlikely,
one of the biggest champions of my book
is a conservative Evangelical Christian
in Mississippi called Christina Dennis,
who's doing incredible work with this,
right?
And I thought a lot about Filippone when
I went to go and see Phillip Ahmed on
the downtown east side,
and he said to me,
he would sacrifice his entire political
career all over again given the chance
for this course.
He said,
how often do you get to save thousands
of lives at the most vulnerable people?
And after I got to know Bud Osborne,
the guy who started this movement, um,
he died. He, he, uh, I remember, uh, you
know, he's only in his early sixties,
but he'd been a homeless
addict during a drug war.
It takes a toll on you and they sealed
off the streets of the downtown east side
where bought had lived as a homeless
person and they had this incredible
memorial ceremony and there were loads
of people at that ceremony who knew that
they were alive because
of what buttered started.
And because so many other people have
joined them and so many people who didn't
have addiction problems had
opened their hearts. Right.
And I remember thinking that day, you
know, when you get disheartened about,
they said it's easy to get disheartened,
right?
This is a hundred year long drug war.
Um,
we're up against very powerful forces.
Everyone watching your show,
listening to your show is more
powerful than bud was that day, right?
The day he started that, right? It just,
by virtue of the fact they have a device
on which to listen to this, right,
but didn't sit there thinking
someone else is going to handle this.
He didn't sit there thinking,
oh well this is doubled up against
these forces that can't be defeated.
He started where he stood.
He appealed to the people around him and
it started this circle of change that,
you know,
the Canadian Supreme Court ruled that
because the right wing government of
Stephen Harper tried to shut
down this injection site. Um,
and the Canadian Supreme Court ruled
that people with addiction promise have a
right to light, to live, and
that includes a safe place.
You said it looks like will never be
taken away now, right? That static is one,
but you know, when you have
nothing else, you have a voice.
You have a human voice that you can use
to persuade other people with love and
compassion.
You can tell them stories.
You can build people's love and compassion
in the middle of this catastrophe
that we're seeing in this country with
the addiction crisis. Right? I mean,
more people died last year and the opioid
crisis than all the soldiers who died
in the Vietnam war combined
in the middle of this catastrophe.
We can carry on doing what we've been
doing. Okay. We can carry on doing that,
then we will continue to get the
horrific results we are now getting.
We can continue to copy the
places that have failed, right?
At the end of a hundred year long
drug war, those cost $1 trillion.
We can't even keep drugs out of our
prisons where we have a wall perimeter and
we pay people to walk
around at the whole time.
So good luck keeping them out
of a 3000 mile border. Right?
That will never happen.
That is a ludicrous fantasy.
He might as well take all the money that
will be spent on trying to keep drugs
out. That way I'm burning it
in a pile. Right, is absurd.
There's never been such a society.
Um,
all we can start to copy the places
that have, right Portugal, Switzerland,
Urgh why Canada?
There are plenty of places that have
tried the alternatives and people who were
quite skeptical.
It's one thing that was most striking
to me in all those places is that people
who were initially skeptical
and initially thought it was crazy,
very often change their minds.
This is the consistent pattern
before it happens.
People think it's the work of bunch
of fucking Wackos. They think,
why people who want to,
you know,
get everyone to use drugs and get children
to use drugs and think it's madness.
And then they see that that's not at all
what motivates people who want reform.
And that's not, that's not what
happens in practice when you,
when you adopt these policies,
and it's not a magic bullet
and they still have problems,
but there's been such a significant
improvement in all those places.